نَحْنُ الخُضَارْ نَحْنُ الخُضَارْ
بِالخَيْرِ نَأْتِي لِلْصِغَارْ
خِيَارٌ ..خِيَارْ Cucumber
مَا أَحْلَى لَوْنِي الأَخْضَرْ
طَازَجْ وَمُفِيدٌ لِلْهَضْم
بَصَلٌ بَصَلْ Onion
أنَا بَيْنَ الخُضَرِ بَطَلْ
أنَا فِي المَطْبَخِ أَنَا الكُل
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا نَحْنُ الخُضَارْ نَحْنُ الخُضَارْ
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا نَحْنُ بِالخَيْرِ نَأْتِي لِلْصِغَارْ
طَمَاطِمْ طَمَاطِمْ tomato
أُصْلُحُ خُضَرا وفَوَاكِهْ
حَمْرَاءٌ وَوُجُودِى مُهِمْ
قَرْنَبِيطْ cauliflower
لَوْنِي أَبْيَضْ وَ أَخْضَرْ
تَأْكُلُنِي حَتْما سَتَكْبُر
نَحْنُ الخُضَارْ نَحْنُ الخُضَارْ
بِالخَيْرِ نَأْتِي لِلْصِغَارْ
جَزَرٌ جَزَرْ carrot
أَنَا أُقًوِّي النَّظَرْ
لِتَرَى الدُنْيَا وَالقَمَرْ
بَطَاطِسْ بطاطسْ potato
أَنَا رَائِعَةٌ مَحْبُوبَة
وَبِالأَطْبَاقْ مَطْلُوبَة
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا نَحْنُ الخُضَارْ نَحْنُ الخُضَارْ
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا نَحْنُ بِالخَيْرِ نَأْتِي لِلْصِغَارْ
vegetables